many Clark County Schools wrapped up
Nevada reading week to highlight the
importance of reading but for students
at Bozarth Elementary School their
excitement about reading it's year-round
as Victoria Saha found it's thanks to a
new machine that gives them a book of
their choice
[Music]
this is
reading is a big deal for the students
in Miss Amanda gubler's library then you
start to know more words and you
recognize them with all the technology
that we have in front of us the joy and
the magic that holding a physical book
in your hands and owning it is important
not like me brown bear brown bear was my
very first book that I remember getting
to keep but these days the students at
Bozarth Elementary are getting their
first book through a reward system and
it all starts with good behavior no it's
not a snack waiting at the bottom of the
vending machine it's a book I was so
excited I think there was three or four
slots empty and it was full this morning
you get to keep the books and you get
the read them when you want to this
vending machine doesn't take cash or
card it only accepts a gold coin you can
get a gold coin only if you saved up 20
champ tickets so how do you get your
hands on one of those being quiet in
class and
participating in special second grader
Brody Cullen has been on his best
behavior as he saved up his champ
tickets and he finally had enough to get
a gold coin it's a moment he's been
waiting for
a new tool changing the lives of
students one book at a time Victoria
Saha 8 News Now